o que você é capaz de estabelecer
relações de verdadeira intimidade com
pessoas da sua família com seus cônjuges
com seus amigos você é capaz de
estabelecer relações de verdadeira gente
de verdadeira intimidade com você mesmo
nós vivemos hoje segundo os filósofos
tempos que são chamados de tempos
líquidos
eu sou parte desses tempos vocês também
o que são tempos líquidos tempos
líquidos são tempos onde nós não temos
mais certeza de nada onde as famílias
antes estruturas muito firmes muito
confiáveis
o alicerce da nossa sociedade na verdade
se diz constituem aos nossos olhos
casamentos casamentos duradouros para o
resto da vida eu particularmente já
casei três vezes
espero não casar mais nenhuma enfim
mas o que acontece a ciência dona das
verdades absolutas um espaço de
conhecimento também que parece
absolutamente confiável na realidade
traz apenas uma perspectiva de
provisoriedade e nós estamos aí
envolvidos nesse mesmo processo no
processo de se sentir de alguma forma
inseguros e encantados pela infinitude
de possibilidades que nós temos para
acessar e para encontrar aquilo que nós
buscamos todos como seres humanos que é
o processo de auto realização ea
conquista da felicidade
o tema da minha fala hoje é o tema de
autoconhecimento solução de conflitos
propósito de vida e felicidade e quando
a gente vai pensar um pouquinho sobre o
que é a felicidade
se nós fizéssemos uma pequena viagem num
curto espaço de tempo pensando nas moças
do século 20
metade do século 20 e década de 60
o que a gente imagina que faria uma moça
feliz naquela época fazer o curso normal
ser professora era o típico a escolha
quase que generalizada para todas as
moças da época encontrar um bom partido
para se casar na época se chamava os o
pão aquele rapaz é um pão é e constituir
uma família onde todos então em paz e em
harmonia ficariam lá até o próximo
processo de envelhecimento separar-se um
do outro e agora o que faz as moças o
que faz os homens as mulheres as
crianças os idosos felizes
o que faz você feliz você já se
perguntou já se fez essa pergunta
estudos e e eu trabalho como pesquisador
e professor universitário há muitos anos
investigando o processo de auto
realização e de auto conhecimento humano
e tentando entender um pouquinho como é
que as pessoas lidam com os seus
conflitos internos e externos
na medida em que a gente vai se
aprofundando os conhecimentos a respeito
do cérebro se consolida ainda mais o
entendimento de que o nosso aparelho
psíquico ele se subdivide em três partes
basicamente uma que nós chamamos de
consciente e que todos nós conhecemos
a outra que nós chamamos de inconsciente
que se subdivide segundo um psicólogo é
muito apreciado a tal atualmente em duas
partes que seria o inconsciente pessoal
inconsciente coletivo
só estou me referindo neste momento ao
psicólogo carlos gustav jung
como é que o que isso pende importante
para nós neste momento quando a gente
pensa em felicidade um propósito de vida
em autoconhecimento
ora nós estamos acostumados a viver numa
sociedade em que só olhamos para fora
somos treinados o tempo todo a procurar
nas prateleiras do supermercado ou nas
prateleiras do shopping centers
os produtos que vão garantir a nossa
felicidade é lá é pagando é numa
sociedade absolutamente consumista
de consumo que nós encontramos o sentido
das nossas vidas
será já dizia o filósofo bauru em que
nós vivemos um processo constante de
coisificação do homem das relações
humanas e nessa roda viva da vida
nós nos perdemos de nós mesmos um
exemplo roupas como é comum
nós nos nos olharmos para as tendências
de moda e de repente dizendo como é que
é possível que usa roupa que coisa mais
ridícula mais feia mas estranha mais
desconfortável passa mês
estamos nós lá com a tal da roupinha
porque será que isso acontece porque nós
somos de certa forma marionetes desse
sistema que nos cria grande armadilha de
que mais fujamos de nós mesmos
ao longo desse nesses anos de trabalho
então me vi pensando como é que é
possível fugir dessa engrenagem tão
perversa
será que é ou será que nós estamos
fadados a ficar o tempo inteiro
mergulhando dentro desse buraco negro
que se cria em cada um de nós em que as
a satisfazer as necessidades na
realidade é algo praticamente
inatingível
nós vivemos como seres humanos
sentimentos de angústia de ansiedade de
insatisfação e não sabemos bem porque
escolhemos em função das escolhas que a
sociedade nos coloca e nos desconectamos
cada vez mais de nós mesmos
na medida em que a gente vai estudando e
pesquisando as diversas formas de reação
humana eu fui descobrindo uma coisa que
é muito antiga chamada de auto
conhecimento auto conhecimento tão
simples trabalhado desde a grécia antiga
ou muito antes
o que significa isso simples demais
criar um tempo criar uma prática para
olhar pra mim mesmo e ao longo dessas
pesquisas e fui descobrindo também que
pessoas que não se auto conhecem são
incapazes de produzir uma coisa preciosa
nas relações interpessoais chamada
empate
é o que a empatia empatia é a capacidade
que eu tenho de me colocar no lugar do
outro do ponto de vista do outro
calçar os sapatos do outro o que
acontece é que nós não temos mais
condição de desenvolver a condição
empática por que isso acontece
isso acontece porque se o meu ponto de
partida eu é obscuro desconhecido como
serei eu capaz de ler o outro isso é
possível
bem então ao longo dessa minha caminhada
como pesquisador e acima de tudo como
ser humano que também persegue o
autoconhecimento como uma prática diária
de busca pela felicidade e fui passear
de mãos dadas com cargos teve um
tentando entender que na realidade nós
somos compostos por personagens
interiores e que em vez de ficar o tempo
todo me projetando pra fora eu deveria
criar uma prática e estimular para que a
cultura ocidental dentro do espaço onde
eu atuo pudesse de alguma forma
valorizar o processo de incursão de
viagem interior
e foi aí então que eu descobrir que na
realidade nós temos dentro de nós
personagens anteriores que nós
desconhecemos que são chamados de
arquétipos que são arquétipos arquétipos
são justamente esses registros que são
passados de geração para geração
relativos às experiências vividas pela
humanidade e que compõem o nosso
inconsciente coletivo o que é o
inconsciente coletivo inconsciente
coletivo nós falamos tanto de redes
sociais é uma espécie de rede social
interna que cada um de nós possui e que
se comunica com a rede social interna do
outro então na medida em que eu me deixe
seduzir me deixa encantar por essa
possibilidade de viajar pra dentro de
mim eu começo a me perguntar quem sou eu
de verdade e quem é você de verdade por
que razão você nasceu
estudos da universidade de harvard vai
mostrar que nós temos uma coisa chamada
de centro de bem estar que também é de
natureza que típica e que nos
analisa-se uma determinada experiência é
considerada boa ou ruim
através de sensações quem de nós quando
lembra da infância não tem algumas
experiências que já era um frio na
barriga por ser uma sensação de mal
estar
ou então quando nós sentimos
determinados cheiros quando nós ouvimos
determinadas músicas nós não acabamos
experimentando aquela experiência de
novo todos nós temos isso e esse centro
de bem-estar serve justamente para
sinalizar as escolhas são tantas as
escolhas são tantas as possibilidades
que temos como fazemos para fazer a
escolha certa a escolha certa está
sinalizada por esse centro de bem estar
esse sinalizador interno auto regulador
que na realidade vai dizer vá por aqui
não vá por ali porque nós somos tão
surdos a esse centro porque não estamos
conectados conosco mesmos
autoconhecimento significa conexão e
aqui eu faço um convite para que nós
possamos pensar um pouquinho sobre
quatro grandes arquétipos sobre quatro
grandes personagens interiores que todos
nós temos dentro de nós mesmos e que na
realidade coordena os nossos processos
de querer pensar sentir e fazer todos
vocês têm esses arquétipos eu tenho esse
arquétipo na medida em que nós esses
arquétipos perdão e na medida em que nós
não entramos em contato com eles e eles
acabam agindo individualmente nos
puxando uma hora por um lado outra hora
pra outro quando o pensar não está
conectado com o querer que não está
conectado como sentir que não está
conectado como fazer o que acontece
conosco acontece essa vida organizada
pela busca e pelo desencontro do sentido
constantes
então o arquétipo do sonhador é aquele
arquétipo relacionado com a nota o nosso
desejo com os nossos sonhos com a nossa
coragem de criar e de perseguir um sonho
todos nós temos isso ele está ligado à
função do querer
o pensador
é tipo que nos faz analisar situações
nos faz pensar aplicar fatos e lógica
sobre as coisas que nós vivemos ponderar
as conseqüências dos nossos atos
o arquétipo do amante é aquele
responsável pelas nossas pelos nossos
sentimentos pelas nossas emoções pela
capacidade que nós temos de estabelecer
uma relação de confiança com os outros e
o arquétipo do guerreiro é aquele
responsável pelas nossas ações por
aquilo que nós fazemos
pensei numa orquestra imaginem só que
daqui a pouco nós estamos encantandos um
rock outro tocando música antiga outro
tocando salsa e outro tocando um a uma
pensão bomba que acontece aí se nós não
nos auto conheciam se nós não investimos
essa escuta o centro de bem-estar
acontece essa bagunça e não aquilo que
nós podemos ouvia que antes tão bem
interpretado pelo fernando não é
então agora eu queria fazer um teste
zinho rápido com vocês por favor eu vou
fazer de conta aqui que façam de conta
comigo que você tem o companheiro de
você está dizendo isso pra vocês e eu
quero que vocês selecione pautas
alternativas você se encaixariam mais
não é um teste preciso é apenas um
levantamento
aí eu peço que vocês levantem a mão
depois quem se encaixa mais a resposta
estou precisando fazer muito mais viagem
é o companheiro de vocês com a
companheira de vocês dizendo isso pra
vocês
certo sei que não temos dinheiro mas
estou exausto estafado preciso
recarregar as baterias
a primeira resposta vocês agora
adorei a ideia só posso imaginar nós
dois com uma cervejinha uma espumante
tanto faz o sol brilhando vento gostoso
perfeito segunda resposta
acho que já estamos no nosso orçamento
podemos calcular o custo de uma viagem
de fim de semana comparar as despesas
com nossa economia e depois decidir o
quanto podemos gastar terceira resposta
não sabia que você andava tão cansado
você quer conversar sobre isso quarta
resposta
você fizer um monte de horas extras na
próxima semana e não saímos para jantar
fora
vai dar para pagar os cartões de crédito
do contrário uma viagem está fora de
questão
pergunta pra vocês se vocês estivessem
na condição do interlocutor do
companheiro de vocês quem responderia a
opção 1 por favor levante a mão muito
bem quem responderia a opção 2 levante a
mão quem responderia a opção 3 e quem
responderia opção 4
o que eu quero dizer com isso quem
respondeu a opção 1 tem o sonhador como
arquétipo predominante
quem respondeu opção 2 tem o pensador e
aqui nós temos uma maioria de pensadores
e de sonhadores quem respondeu a opção 3
tem o amante como arquétipo predominante
e quem respondeu a opção 4 tem o
guerreiro como aspecto predominante a
keko perdão
qual é a ideia desse processo é que
esses quatro qat pus trabalhem juntos
ancorados no nosso centro de bem estar
se acontecer isso o que nós temos nós
temos o ponto de partida o gatilho dado
para a nossa viagem de autoconhecimento
e aí e os conflitos que nós temos nós
vamos conseguir resolvê los de forma
adequada claro que sim porque porque na
realidade quando eu tenho clareza sobre
mim mesmo sobre quem eu sou eu não
preciso entender o conflito como uma
situação de disputa com o outro eu vou
entender os conflitos como um problema
que eu tenho pra resolver e que na
realidade eu enxergo o meu interlocutor
como um parceiro para dividir esse
problema eu não tô numa arena tentando
derrubar o outro não é uma relação de
ganhar e perder e sim uma relação de
ganhar ganhar propósito de vida
nós temos um tesouro guardado dentro de
nós se movem empreendemos nessa viagem
de autoconhecimento sim
nós escutamos o nosso centro de bem
estar se nós valorizarmos a nossa
inteligência intuitiva aqui dentro está
o nosso propósito de vida não está do
lado de fora não está nas prateleiras do
supermercado não está no shopping center
está aqui dentro e uma vez que eu
consiga empreender esse processo eu
consigo acessar esse propósito de vida e
quem acessa o propósito de vida acessa a
felicidade ea felicidade meus amigos não
é um processo de só sorrisos
a felicidade às vezes envolve choro e
envolve tristeza e envolve raiva mas
todos esses sentimentos são bem vindos
porque são humanos e devem ser honrados
e acolhidos como uma oportunidade de
aprendizagem cada um é feliz de um jeito
e somente através desse processo de
inclusão naquilo que nós somos é que nós
vamos poder sentir o que faz o nosso
coração vibrar como diz o compositor
cada um de nós acompanhe a sua história
e cada ser em si carrega o dom de ser
capaz de ser feliz
tenham coragem coloquem o coração em
ação e sejam muito mas muito feliz
o